salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
j'espère que vous allez bien nous
aujourd'hui nouveau spot sous un pont à
côté d'une grande ville ouais ça devrait
pas mal ça va déjà et est visiblement au
sais pas si ça fait on parle ou pas on
dirait une sorte de mannequin qui a été
brûlé
vous avez des idées je pense qu'on va
garder pour faire un épouvantail d'un
jardin plutôt ça parle de même une
sculpture peut-être quoi faire sinon
nous on a deux gros espoirs pour cette
partie de pêche on a à côté d'une grande
ville donc possible le taux de
criminalité élevé ouais on va voir ça on
s'est un peu assez fréquentes et donc y
aura pas de choses trop volumineuse
lorsqu'on pense à beaucoup de voitures
qui passent mais il peut y avoir
quelques petites choses intéressantes
que je vous propose c'est qu'on a pas
que tu te fais
avoir rasta et encore pour cette partie
pêche
à ses gardes ah ouais ça commence bien
super double clé
à
oui un truc ici là
de grosse taille plutôt
froid j'ai un bout
où je les mets en entier
c'est quoi
étonnant
aa de l'est
c'est lourd
aussi
pareil
y'a pas moyen de savoir
si bizarre comme c'est un produit d'un
système qui s'ouvrent
les parasols twente et parasols transats
ouais
à une un pignon de bello
d'olive où il ya des trucs va falloir
bien celle là bas
tout le monde
3g un bâton aussi aux non pas du fait qu
on
compte un motivateur
ça c'est pas une vmc
chauffage
il était attaché cepedant
avait de l'eau de l'eau qui est en jeu
c'est ça au moins dans new way on dirait
une viennent suivre
terme haulotte protections occultes
d'accord bon ben c'est bien
une capsule
il ya un truc qui s'y
tient parce qu'un numéro de série mais
opel tient pour sa voiture voilà voilà
c'est un morceau qui manquent on l'a
pêché
way
c'est lourd et
d'abord
c'est coloré au bout c'est bon tout ça
ouais
des boules pc pour un transformateur
vous rêvez plus tôt ianoukovitch avait
un bon couteau ça c'est une arme de
crime ça c'est clairement énorme bassin
ouais il est 9 regard du droit du sang
tu crois à temps
non c'est la rouille
c'est la wii
c'est sûr
bailly la vie mais quand même à la trace
il était même passé un moment dans l'eau
ouais ok vitesse du sens et pas à la
poutre ou
trois que andry sais pas
une vidéo
ces deux grottes de han weeds ça s'est
produit doit
du sparadrap c'est un bouchon ouais des
pochons du sparadrap encore un couteau
non mais ça donne pour couper là le shit
make a wave c'est pour couper la chique
ouais
alors ce transformateur avec
c'est quand même bizarre quelques
matériels de petits dealers
ont gardé son fondateur
bâle est
doctorant starter santé has et super
récente de son câble ouais
les plus gros ouais
pareil ça devient intéressant sauce pop
ouais surtout ce vide du coup
tu voulais sentir non annoncés ce pc 1
on t'as fait ça sous le pont du coup
ouais
il est sympa ce prochain week-end more
thing pas mal la mode en ce moment de
faire des pochons un petit peu custom
nokia par exemple les pochons emmanuel
macron qui sont qui sont très beaux les
pochons dupond moretti voilà petit petit
clin d'oeil à la justice de ce pays et
les pochons homer simpson pour
lesquelles j'ai un petit coup de coeur
personnellement ntang pas de baisser la
rattraper
ya joué
dans le pont
vers le haut je sais que ça encore ah ça
c'est une lampe à uv pour l'a8 aux
[ __ ]
c'est une lampe à uv les gars
trop vite
ils ont senti venir la paire qu'ils
aient déjà
l'ampoulé cas c'est
énorme j'étais à changer dans cool
qu'il est je suis c'est ce qu'il est
matériel du parfait dealer
alors la boucle un destin de weeds
mmmmh l'aération mec c'était pour ça et
ouais ouais et là et l'alimentation
électrique aussi
bonjour
[Musique]
apache aller m'en remettre tout ce qui
est puissant et on récupère du lecteur
ferraille qui sont tout ce qui est
métallique à
nettoyer des trouvailles
merci
[Musique]
sans la merde
merci
ouais forcément du dealer a même pas un
manceau de cadres
c'était le père du saas et pluvieux
ça peut aider les inquiète aussi
je vous signale qu'il faut bosser ouais
c'est ça j'ai l'habitude
bon
la cruche
énorme pas exploser
donc la trouvais sympa un porte-monnaie
en cuir voyez totalement bayard et à
l'intérieur mais ça reste très sympa
voilà première pour moi un porte-monnaie
[Musique]
dans un tube
hockey
aaa est un très bon saut bord
je les
vois la régie bizarrement comme s'il y
avait une partie des chaînes ou quoi une
partie qui est tenu dans le sol
c'est quoi que ce soit c'est ça regardez
mieux dans le même
genre 20 elle est hyper envasé
où
ça ça fait du poids je te le dis le
ferrailleur il va être encore
un battant on reste ça va être super lot
on tire
c'est hyper crus locaux
via l'offre au bout ça serait cool est
peut-être ah bah oui oui à lille non
non et encore
un anneau
pourquoi
n'y a pas d'encre
poirier du poil ouais
il est plaqué au sol ok tu perds pour
ceux qui ne sont pas familiers avec ce
type de matériel nous vous avons préparé
une petite animation sur cette image
vous retrouvez les lampes uv donc comme
celle que nous avons péché souvent elles
sont équipées de programmateurs afin
d'assurer un ensoleillement maximum pour
vos plants de tomates ces lampes uv sont
aussi couplé avec des ventilateurs donc
qui permettent de garder un petit vent
permanent dans la pièce idéale pour le
développement des plantes vous avez
aussi une vmc donc un petit peu comme
celle qu'on a péché elles sont aussi
souvent équipés de différents filtres
donc des filtres à charbon parfois pour
pour justement empêcher l'odeur de se
propager dans tout le quartier ici nous
avons un ballast électronique donc ce
type de ballast permet d'avoir un très
bon rendement lumineux mais surtout de
garantir un éclairage constant pour
convenir à l' équilibre des plantes à la
petite
passé et qu'il évite
donc de
porter de cannabis en vrai c'est génial
j'arrivais à chanter tomber naturel
j'avais tout est moins sympa donc pour
est recherché par
la police
wave actuellement des jeunes filles
[Musique]